>> Laura: OH, BOY, DO WE HAVE
A LOT TO GET TO.
I HAVE TO JUMP RIGHT IN.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW, RUDY
GIULIANI.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AND SARAH YOU
ARE NOT IN THE STUDIO BUT WE
HAVE SOME MAJOR BREAKING NEWS WE
NEED TO GET TO AND JUST MOMENTS.
FIRST YOUR REACTION TO THE
DEMOCRATS ASKING BILL BARR TO
NSN'S FOUL THE LEGAL BOUNDARIES
OF REVIEWING THIS REPORT FOR
GRAND JURY CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION.
THEY SUBPOENA ABOUT TODAY IT WAS
LONG PARTY LINES BUT THEY ARE
THROWING DOWN THE GOT LENT.
WHAT YOUR REACTION?
>> THEY ARE PROVING THAT THEY
ARE RABID ARTISTS AND DEMOCRATS
WHO SHOULD NOT BE INVESTIGATING
SOMETHING WHERE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOME DEGREE OF OBJECTIVITY AND
FAIRNESS BEFORE YOU CALL PEOPLE
BEFORE COMMITTEES.
THEY OBVIOUSLY HAVE NONE.
THEY HAVE NO REGARD FOR THE
CONSTITUTION AND LAWS.
I CAN SHOW YOU LETTERS FROM THEM
THAT WOULD BE A JOKE IN TERMS OF
TOTAL DISREGARD FOR THE CLIENT
PRIVILEGE AS IF IT DOESN'T EXIST
AND NOW THEY WANT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO VIOLATE RULE
62 IS A FEDERAL FELONY.
THEY WOULD LIKE HIM TO VIOLATE
POSSIBLY LAWS REGARDING
CLASSIFICATION, POSSIBLY DAMAGE
INNOCENT REPUTATION.
THE REALITY IS, I AM CONFIDENT
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL
PUT OUT A VERY COMPLETE PART, IF
NOT ALL OF IT, WHATEVER HE CAN
LEGALLY.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD CHANGE THE
LIFE THEY WANT TO.
EVERY GRAND JURY OR GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY IS OPEN TO EVERYBODY
AND THERE IS NO ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE.
MAYBE YOU DO AWAY --
THEY DID AWAY WITH THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE FOR TWO
YEARS.
THEIR DISREGARD FOR THE
CONSTITUTION IS MIND-BOGGLING
AND FRIGHTENING.
>> Laura: THEY DIDN'T WANT
THAT RELEASE AND NOW IT IS A
DIFFERENT DEAL.
THEY CLAMPED THAT THE PRESIDENT
INITIALLY SAID HE WANTS IT ALL
OUT AND NOW THEY ON THAT.
THEIR MESSAGES WHAT DO YOU HAVE
TO HIDE?
>> THE PRESIDENT ACTUALLY CAN'T
HAVE IT ALL OUT EITHER.
HE CAN'T OVERRIDE THE LAW.
HE CAN'T SAY OKAY, THE GRAND
JURY SECRECY DOESN'T MATTER.
ONLY A JUDGE COULD DO THAT UNDER
VERY NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES AND
YOU KNOW THAT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE LAWLESS, A
JOKE.
THERE ARE LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY
AND REPUBLICANS GET THE BENEFIT
OF LAWS AND NOT JUST DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTED HOURS AGO ON THE LEFT
IS GOING GAGA, THE MUELLER TEAM
MEMBERS THINK THEIR FINDINGS ARE
MORE DAMAGING FOR TRUMP THAN THE
BARMAID OUT IN HIS MEMORY FOUR
PAGE LETTER.
THEY CONVENIENTLY LEAVE OUT
WHICH TEAM MEMBERS ARE UPSET AND
WHAT FINDINGS THEY HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY KIND OF, A
LOT OF DEMOCRATIC LOYALISTS THAT
TEAMS, BUT IT SEEMS THEY ARE
FEELING THE HEAT.
DOES THIS SEEM TO BE A
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED LEAK OF
GRIEVANCES?
>> [LAUGHS]
IT MAKES THE POINT WE HAVE BEEN
MAKING FOR TWO YEARS DESPITE ALL
THE MEDIA REPORTS WITH HOW HOLY
AND SAINT TIMONEY US THE MUELLER
TEAM IS.
THEY ARE A BUNCH OF STICKY
UNETHICAL LEAKERS.
THEY HEAR THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES AND I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW MUCH PAUL'S INFORMATION
THEY HAVE LEAKED.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD BE
INDICTED THAT DIDN'T?
HOW MANY BLOCKBUSTERS WERE THER
THERE?
ENDING WITH MICHAEL COHEN WHO
WAS A SERIAL LIAR.
HOW COULD YOU HAVE ANY
CONFIDENCE AND THIS?
>> Laura: I JUST HAD RICHARD
GOODSTEIN ON AND HE SAID, WHY
WERE THEY NOT TELLING THE FULL
TRUTH ABOUT THESE CONTACTS WITH
RUSSIANS?
I LOOKED AT HIM AND I SAID, ARE
YOU STILL SAYING?
THAT ISN'T THE CASE.
>> THAT IS THE FULL TRUTH BY THE
WAY.
THE MEETING WAS ABOUT THE ACT
AND ADOPTION.
>> Laura: I HAVE TWO RUSSIAN
SOUNDS, I KNOW ALL ABOUT IT
BELIEVE ME.
THEY HAVE NOT LET IT GO.
THEY NOW THINK WITH THIS
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT THAT
THEY WILL HAVE --
THERE WILL BE.
IN THIS MUELLER REPORT AND THEY
WANTED RELEASED LIKE YESTERDAY.
HE WILL HAVE A BIG PROTEST.
THEY HAVE TO RELEASE THIS THING
ON REDACTED AND YOU CAN SEE THEY
HAVE TO KEEP FEEDING THE BEAST.
>> AM CONFIDENT THAT THE REPORT
WILL BEAR OUT THE CONCLUSIONS,
NO OBSTRUCTION, NO RUSSIAN
COLLUSION OF ANY KIND.
IT WILL BEAR THAT OUT.
WHETHER THEY CAN TAKE SOME FACTS
AND TWIST THEM ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER, WE ARE READY TO HER ABOUT
THAT.
I'VE BEEN READY TO REBUT THAT
FOR FOUR MONTHS.
WE THINK WE CAN PROVE BEYOND ANY
DOUBT THAT THERE IS NOTHING TO
COLLUSION AND I DON'T THINK THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT COLLUSION.
>> Laura: ADAM SCHIFF SAID
THAT THERE IS PLENTY OF EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION AND CORRUPT
COMINGLING OF WORK BETWEEN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIANS.
HE SAID THAT THIS MORNING >> I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS ANYTHING
LEFT OF HIS REPUTATION.
THE REALITY IS THAT THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
LET ME GIVE YOU ONE OVERVIEW OF
OBSTRUCTION.
HOW COULD THERE BE OBSTRUCTION
WANT TO A MUELLER COMPLETED HIS
INVESTIGATION AND NOBODY
OBSTRUCTED IT?
DID SOMEBODY THINK ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION?
THAT IS NOT A CRIME!
>> Laura: THEY ARE MAD.
>> WHAT WAS THIS?
MUELLER GOT 500 WITNESSES, HE
SPENT $40 MILLION.
HE GOT TO HIS CONCLUSION WITHOUT
ANYONE INTERFERING WITH THEM.
THIS WILL BE THE STRANGEST
OBSTRUCTION CASE I EVER SAW.
>> Laura: WILL HE STILL STAY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> HE IS SUCH A GOOD LAWYER AND
THIS ISN'T THE ONLY THING HE
DOES >> IT KEEPS GOING.
HE IS A CRITICAL PART OF THE
PRESIDENT'S TEAM.
I'VE HAD THE HONOR OF WORKING
WITH HIM BUT I THINK HE IS A
GREAT LAWYER AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WE GOT THE RESULT.
>> Laura: I HAVE TO PLAY ADAM
SCHIFF.
HE JUST HAD THIS MOMENTS AGO.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHY DIDN'T HE RELEASE A
SUMMARY PRODUCED BY BOB MUELLER
HIMSELF INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
SHAPE IT THROUGH HIS OWN WORDS?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO MAKE OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT.
IT IS CONCERNING.
WE WILL FIGHT THIS AND ANYWAY WE
CAN AND NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GOT TO
SEE THE PRODUCT OF BOB MUELLER'S
WORK WITHOUT THE FILTER OF
MR. TRUMP'S HANDPICKED
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Laura: IT WILL RIDE THIS
THIS ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH 2020.
>> IT WILL WRITE IT RIGHT TO
MAKING THEMSELVES EVEN MORE
INCREDIBLE.
THAT MAN SHOULD BE ASHAMED FOR
HIS DISGRACEFUL CONDUCT AND
SAYING THAT HE HAD EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
WHERE'S THE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION?
DID YOU GIVE IT TO MUELLER?
YOU WEREN'T TELLING THE TRUTH
AND YOU ARE NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH NOW.
YOU ARE SUCH A OVERWHELMED
PARTISAN AND YOUR HATRED OF
TRUMP YOU CAN'T EVEN SEE THE
TRUTH.
>> Laura: THE ISSUE OF THE TAX
RETURN CAME UP AGAIN TODAY THAT
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS FORMALLY
REQUESTED SIX YEARS OF THE
PRESIDENTS PERSONAL AND BUSINESS
TAX RETURNS.
WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO COME
AND THEY WANT THEM --
YOU HAVE A PEN?
THEY WANT ONE A WEEK FROM TODAY.
HE WAS THE PRESIDENT'S RESPONSE.
>> THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MOMENTS AGO ASKED THE IRS FOR
SIX YEARS?
>> IS THAT ALL?
USUALLY IT IS TEN.
I GUESS THEY ARE GIVING UP.
DESPITE WHAT PEOPLE SAY, WE ARE
WORKING THAT OUT.
>> Laura: IT IS LUDICROUS.
WHY IS BEING UNDER AUDIT DOING
THAT?
>> THE REAL REASON IS THAT THIS
WAS NOT THE IRS.
HE IS COMPLETELY DISTORTING OUR
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS NOT AN ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY.
THEY DON'T GET TO LOOK AT MY TAX
RETURNS FOR YEARS.
>> Laura: THEY ARE GOING RIGHT
TO THE IRS AND NOT ASKING TRUMP.
THEY ARE GOING TO THE IRS WHICH
IS UNPRECEDENTED.
>> THE IRS WILL HAVE TO RESIST
IT BECAUSE IT IS TOTALLY
ILLEGAL.
THERE IS NO BASIS FOR IT AND
THEY ARE NOT THE IRS.
THEY DON'T INVESTIGATE TAX FRAUD
OR IRREGULARITIES FOR TAX
MISTAKES.
IF THEY START INVESTIGATING PAT,
EVERYBODY GOT UPSET WHEN NIXON
DID THIS.
THIS IS AROUND US.
IF THESE POLITICIANS CAN GET
THEIR HANDS ON TAX RETURNS AND
THEY GO AFTER THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, WHAT HAVE WE
BECOME?
IT HAS TO BE RESISTED.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO RESIST THIS
FOR THE GOOD OF ALL OF US.
THEY GET A MEDIA PERSON WHO IS
TOO FAR RIGHT AND THEY WILL GO
AFTER THEIR TAX RETURNS.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY TOMORROW
THEY WILL BE SUBPOENAING THE
GREENS KEEPER AT THE
GOLF COURSE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HE WAS
YOUNGER THEY TELL OF HIS PARKING